okay let's get into this week's much
anticipated hatred mail reminder what is
hatred mail hatred mail is when a
professional voice-over artist does
interpretive readings of hate mail that
I get take a listen hey let's face it
the only logical response to guns is
more freakin guns Patriot mail written
by Patriots who hate David Pakman
because America and because freedom okay
so this week's hatred mail as much of
the hatred mail we received during the
Trump era is eyes about relates to
Donald Trump it relates to Maga or as
this person says magar and it's pretty
unhinged but what we've come to expect
at this point take a listen if this
snowflake Pakman is the best the lib Cox
can do bring it on
sweetie love the people that watch
Pakman is they are 100 percent out of
touch with reality oh no people here
struggle with facts just keep creating
pseudo fake news and cots chambers magar
why is the spelling and grammar' always
atrocious like is it that so I I refuse
to accept that it's just every Trump is
to writes to me doesn't know how to
write in English I think there's got to
be something else to it it's either the
rage so flusters them that they just
lose ability to control their fingers
when they're typing some of it could be
bad voice to text interpretation I don't
know I just don't understand why hatred
mail is just so riddled with typos and
ridiculous grammar and made-up words and
I know we have an education problem in
this country particularly in red states
we know from the data that that's the
case but the frequency with which these
messages are not only angry vitriolic
and and extremely insulting the
frequency with which they just have
spelling and grammar problems is
it's beyond it can't be by chance let me
put it that way make sure that if you
sign up for a membership and you want to
send a middle finger salute to the hey
tree 'it's you sign up using the coupon
code hey tree at forty the coupon code
hey tree at forty saves you 40% and the
hatreds cry whenever that coupon code is
used